big questions for the party immigration
and brexit there still seem to be well
not too many answers let's try and get
some now with Diane Abbott the shadow
home secretary and a very good morning
in a Merry Christmas to you Diana but
interesting we ended our news bulletin
there with picture of Her Majesty the
Queen you're going to be meeting her
soon to be sworn in as a privy council
and you're going to take that oath to be
true and faithful servant I couldn't
possibly comment I couldn't possibly
comment and you know that so but it's
normal for someone in your position on
the front bench to be elected to the
Privy Council it's not if you were you
can have to you're going to have to say
you're going to be a loyal and faithful
servant is that something you would say
with your fingers cross the Proceedings
of the Privy Council are meant to be
private so I can't comment or don't
going to join it and I can't comment I
will need to go to it okay I'm gone
through yeah so I can't comment either
way but I mean you're not in favor
overall you're not in favor of the UK
having a monarchy I mean you've talked
in the past about abolishing it I think
you'll find that was if I did say that's
30 years ago I'm in favor of having a
monarchy the British people have huge
respect for the Queen and I'm in favor
of having a monarchy okay well I also
want to ask you well we're talking about
oaths here then what about this
discussion this morning we're reading in
the papers this oath for civil servants
and others to uphold British values this
suggestion from sagine jovi to address
the problems and we've all talked in the
past and way that the problems of
integration would this be part of the
solution in your view I'm not certain to
anything to deal with a question of
integration or the question of
radicalism however if the Tories really
want people to swear an oath why don't
they part of the oath that's being
suggested is about upholding the legal
system and respect for the law so either
they get some newspaper proprietors to
swear that house because we've seen
terrible coverage in the papers where
they claim that judges are enemy of the
people
maybe if newspaper proprietors swore an
oath to uphold the law who wouldn't see
those ridiculous front pages it was
rather a strange conjunction there
you've made I mean you know that that is
an issue
much-discussed but I can't see making a
much difference where their newspaper
proprietors swore OHS about their
coverage but this issue do you think
it'll make a difference of other
people's fair I'm asking you if you
think it wouldn't make a difference I
have nothing gets influenced but but it
will not make a difference for the
problems of radicalization or
integration but the problems there
I mean you will identify the problems of
people who come to this country who live
in this country were born in this
country who actually feel that many of
the institutions and the values of
Britain do not apply to them or they
want to destroy them I don't make many
people like that I have a very diverse
population in Hackney Muslims West
Indians are people from Turkey so the
living in London and then living in this
country because they value what this
country has to offer and there was they
respects institutions particularly
people who were Jeannette from the
Commonwealth so I don't think the earth
will make any verifiable difference tell
me about this idea of repackaging Jeremy
Corbyn isn't part of his his appeal to
those he appeals to isn't part of his
appeal that he's not packaged that he is
his young man he is what he is I'm
talking about packaging him but I think
he probably will be out in the media
more in the coming year because what we
find is that when Jeremy is actually on
the road or on television actually he
can relate to people and it encourages
people to relate to what he's saying
this is this idea of populism they just
had a panel discussion in the last hour
looking at International Affairs and
some my commentators they're saying well
the thing about populism is that it
doesn't necessarily have to appeal to
the right is that Labour's calculation
yes I mean one of the most populist
American president was FDR is over and
he was very much in an American context
on the Left so populism isn't just about
the right it's about people feeling that
you understand their problems and it's
about people feeling they can actually
relate to you and we think we can do
that on the left as well don't you
Jeremy Corbyn he's talked about people
feeling you understand their problems if
anything the brexit vote told us was
that people have big concerns about the
impact of immigration on their
communities and you and jeremy corbyn
are all on the record as saying you
see the need for any substantial
controls people are very concerned about
the impact immigration on their
communities that's why the Labor Party
is calling for a migration impact phone
to deal with issues around schools and
housing and in particular we want to
crack down on employers who are
exploiting immigrants by beefing up the
factory Inspectorate by enforcement of
the minimum wage by doing away with
explosives in our contract so we take
those things extremely seriously but it
does no good to scapegoat immigrants but
no restriction of numbers there you said
it you will have a mitigation fund you
would put more money into areas where
there are high levels of immigration and
impact on public services but still that
free movement certainly within the
European Union or whatever relationship
we have with the European Union well on
the question of free movement um nobody
is support free movement but it is a
fact that in the EU free movement is one
of the four pillars it's part of the
treaty it's seen as indivisible and non
negotiable and if we want to stay inside
the single market for the benefit of the
economy there's probably going to have
to be some trade-off with freedom of
movement so you would endorse I mean you
were there of course I was true for
Jeremy Corbyn speaks the Labour Party
conference in Liverpool in September
when he addressed immigration head-on
and just before it one of his
spokespeople was was asked to be
explicit about it are you relaxed about
numbers they said yes it's not our
objective to reduce numbers we are
relaxed about numbers going up that
that's the position that was a
spokesperson you have never heard jeremy
say that because it's not his view what
we believe is if we bear down on
exploitation we will bear down on levels
of migration but setting numerical
targets has not worked the Tuohy's has
done it for six years now and
immigrations at record levels we want to
do with the underlying issues in
communities but you won't see the
economy keep growing if the economy
keeps growing it's going to attract more
people here you therefore would be
relaxed about the numbers
in fact with a case of that were the
call well one reason why immigrants have
come here in the past is because some
British workers don't have the right
skills we're really committed to putting
money into education and skills training
and that's another way you bear down on
the numbers of immigrants but as I say
we shouldn't be scapegoating immigrants
but it is a party problem isn't it
because we hear from other members
prominent members of your party lots of
Hilary bankers star Miranda Byrne and
the list goes on the saying well yes we
we do have to do something about the
numbers of course we're going to do
something about the numbers and we're
going to do it by the sorts of skills
training which will mean employers won't
have to bring so many immigrants in and
by bearing down of the other end of the
scale on exploitation which again should
bear down our numbers nobody takes the
issues around people's concerns that let
them to vote for brexit likely well
we're just seeking to address them in a
way that will work so would you endorse
I'm it was Gordon Brown formulated it
wasn't British jobs for British workers
this this is your ambition that's what
that was that was Gordon Brown this is
me I'm saying that we have to put the
economy and jobs and I stand for living
first that we won't skip it immigrants
in fact we think Theresa May should
guarantee the position of a new migrants
who are currently here we will want good
for Britain good for the economy but
we're not about scapegoating people and
blaming immigrants for the failures of
Tory policy on health and house all
right do you think the current number of
strikes are good for good for Britain
and good for the economy we haven't
heard much from the Labour frontbench
about the disruption that's being called
and caused in this this run-up to
Christmas by that rail strikes ones on
there some airlines the postal workers
would you like to say well perhaps you
ought to think about that the public you
serve of course we think about the
public we serve and of course these
strikes going to be right as a stress if
they all go ahead for the public over
Christmas time but people do have a
legal right to strike it's not my role
to second guess decisions of trade union
leadership but in relation to southern
in particular southern has been a
catastrophe we need to take that front
away from southern and give it to the
mayor of London okay I just want to play
to you I took to the chair of the Public
Accounts Committee or your colleague in
the party meg Hillier and this is what
she had to say about that about the
strikes
I think it's absolutely right people
should have
right to strike but I think it is a very
unfortunate combination for people
traveling workers that had a
particularly difficult time of year and
I think that all trade unions even
though they're fighting for their rights
need to really think about the impact on
the people they're actually there to
serve their customers
although passengers and I think that
that needs to Denise to be a bit of a
wake-up call about the impact on
hard-working people who are trying to
get to work or go on holiday and I think
that the if not careful they could be
shooting themselves in the foot shooting
themselves in the foot dynamic discuss
meg is a well-loved colleague in Hackney
I agree with what she said that it's a
really unfortunate situation but I'm not
going to be second-guessing the
leadership of trade unions and we need
to remember it takes two to cause a
strike it's not just the trade union
it's also the problems and incompetence
of some management and southerners an
example of that southern rail I mean but
you don't think some that there's an
agenda beyond protecting the rights of
workers from some of these union leaders
who have talked how they not newbee be
aware of them we've talked about using
it as using strikes as a political
weapon well I don't know about that I
mean the the disputes we are looking at
are genuine industrial disputes and
trade union leadership it's entitled to
take their strategy forward in the way
they think is appropriate and we hope
that some of these strikes won't happen
so what would you say to the government
so we're hearing calls from conservative
MPs some conservative MPs say well you
need new laws to come in here to to
restrict these rights no I would be
opposed to restricting people's right to
strike
there we are shadow home secretary thank
you very much indeed Diane Abbott -
maybe we'll be becoming a member of the
Privy Council but can't tell us we'll
find that very good to see you dine of
it